human aging refers in holy grail study
scientists say human aging process
biologically refers in world fast
right so hello and welcome to the chicky
science show where in this video we're
going to talk about the recent article
that has stimulated
both of these and many other news
articles and we're going to go straight
into the data of this article
and pretty much show why these claims
are definitely over-hyped
and cannot be said from the current
findings
and then we'll talk about why it's so
important to speak out about this
because it really does hurt scientists
by spreading misinformation
so let's jump straight into it then the
study that these articles were referring
to
it's this recent ageing article
hyperbaric
oxygen therapy increases telomere length
and decreases immunosine essence in
isolated blood cells
a prospective trial and this study has
come from a team of israeli
scientists led by professor shea efratti
so what did they do in this study and
what did they actually find out
well the lab are interested in
understanding the physiological effects
of hyperbaric oxygen therapy
this therapy involves breathing pure
oxygen
in a pressurized chamber such that it is
higher than the atmospheric pressure
hence hyperbaric and so this is why it
differs to
normoboric oxygen therapy which is the
type of oxygen that's commonly used in
hospitals and clinics for patients with
lung or heart disease
and hyperbaric oxygen treatment can be
given in two settings
mono place and multi-place whereby mono
place
involves just one person in a single
chamber
where the entire chamber is pressurized
with 100 oxygen
however in the study here they use the
multi-place setting
whereby the chamber is still pressurized
with compressed air
but the patient's individually breathe
100 oxygen for your masks
and so the images you're seeing now
should be very similar to what was used
in this study
and the reason that they use high
pressure comes down to henry's law
that states that the amount of molecular
oxygen dissolved in a solution
so a blood or a tissue is directly
proportional to its partial pressure
so basically by using a hyperbaric high
pressure condition
it enhances the amount of oxygen
dissolved in the body's tissues
and so the same lab reported earlier
this year that by using hyperbaric
oxygen therapy
it induced cognitive enhancements in
healthy adults
involving a mechanism that increased
cerebral blood flow
and so in this study they were more
interested in looking at whether or not
hyperbaric oxygen treatment could also
affect telomere length and the number of
senescent cells
in particular the t cells in aging
adults
so after excluding five participants for
various reasons
30 patients received the therapy and
were assessed
and all these patients were healthy and
they were aged
64 and over and it included both male
and females
and so each of these participants
received 60 daily
hyperbaric oxygen therapy exposures
and so each of these sessions included
breathing 100 oxygen by mask
at two atmospheric pressures for 90
minutes with
5 minute air breaks every 20 minutes and
whole blood samples were taken at the
baseline that's the 30th session
and the 60th session and also one to two
weeks following the last session
and then from this blood they looked at
the peripheral blood mononuclear cells
to assess the telomere length and
senescence
and the reason these two traits were
chosen is because
shortening of telomere length and
telling us in essence
are two of the key hallmarks of aging
telomeres are repetitive dna sequences
that are found
at the end of chromosomes and they act
to maintain genome stability
however as the cell divides they can
shorten over time
and as they shorten it increases the
risk of genomic instability
and so it can cause a cell to enter
replicative senescence
whereby that cell no longer divides and
whilst this is useful
for preventing the over-replication of
cancerous cells
the build-up of senescent cells can
result in chronic inflammation
if the senescent cells are not cleared
due to the fact that these cells can
secrete
a variety of different inflammatory
factors and as i've mentioned in
a few videos before removal of senescent
cells
in most models has been shown to have
beneficial impacts for their health
so let's start with the results
regarding the telomere length
as you can see in these figures here the
telomere lumps of
t helper t cytotoxic natural killer
and b cells all increased significantly
by over 20
following the therapy the most
significant being the increases seen in
the b
cells and so this is interesting however
as pointed out by steve hill
from the life extension advocacy
foundation
and their recent article correctly
stated that t-cells have highly dynamic
telomeres
and they can fluctuate considerably
depending on their situation
for example i reported earlier this year
that telomeres
in peripheral blood mononuclear cells
were lengthened during space flight
and so whilst there's nothing wrong with
the data that they collected
it doesn't necessarily give us any
information regarding the ability to
reverse aging
so now let's look at the senescent cell
data well as you can see in these two
graphs here
one to two weeks post the therapy there
was a significant decrease
in the number of t helper and t
cytotoxic
senescent cells and so the authors
concluded that the hyperbaric oxygen
therapy
may induce significant cenolitic effects
however in this case i am a bit curious
as to how they identified senescent
cells
it seems that they only used one marker
which was the absence
of the protein cd28 and so t-cells
aren't really my speciality
but senescence it kind of is and at
least according to this article
absence of cd28 is the suggested marker
of t-cell senescence
along with a couple of other markers but
what they suggest in this study
is that the best way to be able to
characterize senescence within t
cells is to consider these specific t
cell markers
with the more considered classical
markers of cellular senescence
that includes the presence of sab cigar
staining
and the increased expression of p16 and
p21
and markers of this secretory phenotype
referred to
as the sasp and so from their data it
seems like
this hyperbaric oxygen therapy may be
reducing the number of senescent t cells
but i think that more detailed analyses
are definitely required
to know this for certain and the authors
themselves also pointed out a couple of
other limitations within their study for
example a major limitation is the really
small sample size that they had
and the second is a lack of a control
group that obviously weren't treated
with the hyperbaric oxygen therapy and
they also pointed out as i just stated
regarding the lack of markers used to
identify the senescent cells
and moreover they also stated it would
have been good to
have a better understanding of the
long-term impacts of this therapy
treatment
which they weren't able to assess in the
study and to be honest the list could
really continue i think there's tons of
different markers they could have really
tried to
look at for example what about all the
epigenetic changes that occurred
during this treatment i mean
understandably that's the more expensive
thing to do and
just looking at blood and analyzing
t-cells and a couple of
well one marker of senescence is much
easier to do
but anyway i will be interested to look
into any more studies that
do more in-depth analyses regarding the
impacts of hyperbaric oxygen therapy
however the point of this video wasn't
to criticize in any way this publication
in fact i mean there's nothing wrong
with what they've shown
what is wrong is how this data has been
interpreted by the media
for example if we go back to the article
i said at the start of the video
human aging refers to an holy grail
study scientists say
now sounds kind of ridiculous given the
data that i've just shown
and if we just go to the first sentence
scientists claim to have successfully
reversed the biological aging process
in a group of elderly adults i mean i
hope you can at least agree with me that
the data we've seen have shown
just in some blood cells a
potential decline in the number of
senescent cells
and some increases in the telomere
length
but again these are in cells that have
fluctuating telomere lengths
yeah i mean it's just just not just no
i unless you have no words i mean i've
stated before in videos that it's really
hard to try and
define healthspan and to measure it i
mean it's challenging enough to do this
in mice
let alone in humans and given how small
the sample size is
and the lack of data that was acquired
it's just being very overhyped by the
media
and the problem is to create steve again
it only makes it harder for those of us
who are working
earnestly to support progress and it
also once again serves to highlight the
urgent need for journalists to learn to
discern what study results actually mean
instead of hyping stories to sell papers
which is why on this channel
although at times i may confuse you with
too much science
i do try to go into as much detail as i
can with these studies so that you can
really understand
not just what the answer is but why
that's the answer
and so that you can now read these
articles
with your skeptical hat on and
know better anyway i hope this has given
you at least some
better understanding to this hyperbaric
oxygen
therapy treatment paper and the back
backstory
to these over-hyped news articles so i
hope you have learned something in this
video
and as always thanks for listening